flambée des contaminations en france
jean castex appel ce matin dans la
presse quotidienne régionale les
français à respecter plus que jamais le
confinement de la manière la plus
stricte est possible nouveau record ces
dernières 24 heures avec près de
soixante mille 500 nouveaux cas détectés
à 85 % des lits en réanimation sort est
occupée alors que le seuil des 40 mille
morts n'est plus très loin tout faire
pour éviter la saturation des hôpitaux
jean castex doit se rendre cet après
midi au chu de saint-etienne médecins
généralistes karim khelfaoui était sur
notre antenne ce matin il est revenu sur
l'ambiance qui règne parmi les soignants
écouter convient au niveau des soignants
c'est une extrême tension parce que on
sent bien que l'on il ya un épuisement
ken général qui est là et que ce qui
aurait permis de justement renforcée
notamment à l'hôpital les effectifs pour
soulager un peu tout le monde
ben ça n'a pas été fait donc on demande
aujourd'hui même à des pas des soignants
qui sont positifs au coït et qui sont
symptomatiques de quand même venir
travailler
ce qui est quand même un comble donc là
on a un vrai problème de dépaysement
cette vague s'annonce plus grosse que la
première les lits non de réanimation
notamment n'ont pas été augmentés donc
il ya une énorme crainte oui que les
choses dégénèrent ça c'est sûr